so israeli media is reporting that prime
minister benjamin netanyahu has made a
secret visit
to saudi arabia according to these
reports netanyahu met the crown prince
mohammed bin salman
and the u.s secretary of state mike
pompeo who himself was in israel only
last week
as follows recent washington brokered
normalization deals between
israel the uae and bahrain
harry fawcett's following this one from
ramallah today in the occupied west bank
any confirmation or denial either way
harry
no denial and no official confirmation
but the lack of denial is pretty telling
especially given
the fact that this isn't just one report
it has been pretty widely sourced by a
number of israeli political
journalists and indeed the prime
minister's
own social media comment advisor
put out a tweet saying that while
netanyahu's
coalition partner was playing politics
the prime minister was making peace now
no explicit confirmation of this
particular
visit or potential talks with muhammad
bin salman
in that tweet but the timing was
relatively significant it all came
from initial reports that a business jet
that had been used by the prime minister
in the past that has leased from
an israeli businessman for such uh
high-level trips
uh was spotted making a journey from
israel from tel aviv airport uh at
around 5 p.m local time on sunday
it spent some five hours on the tarmac
at this
red sea resort in saudi arabia before
coming back at the same time there was
supposed to be a coronavirus cabinet
meeting
carried out in the israeli government
that was postponed for
reasons that were said to be about a
lack of preparation on a
digital uh mitigation campaign but that
is now being reported as having been a
cover for what really took place
which is according to these reports that
the prime minister had gone to meet both
secretary of state pompeo u.s secretary
of state and muhammad bin salman the
crown prince
in saudi territory now it's very rare
that this would be
tactically well perhaps saying tacitly
acknowledges a bit too far but certainly
not denied
and certainly apparently reported pretty
widely
does it mean full normalization with
saudi is on the cards
presumably not yet it was just two days
ago that the saudi foreign minister was
saying that
there would have to be a palestinian
state first something that
saudi arabia still ascribes to despite
the fact that the uae bahrain
and sudan have now moved away from that
position we put this to a couple of
senior palestinian officials one said
that
they pointed to that remark from the
foreign minister but said at the same
time there are no guarantees
and others said that they couldn't
comment on it without official
confirmation but said if it had taken
place
this meeting then it would be
heartbreaking
when we look at it in the context harry
of the previous deals as you say the uae
and bahrain already now israel and the
uae we know were already had a
relationship behind the scenes as it
were is there any feeling that that
exists with saudi arabia
as well and that that can contribute to
any further normalization
oh very much so the the israelis and the
saudis have been having
uh clandestine contacts for many years
and so as i say i think the difference
about this one
is how quickly it has come to light and
how little effort appears to be
underway to try to conceal it in
retrospect
or or even you know certainly not deny
that it took place
uh it's also in the context of what we
still presume to be the last few weeks
of the trump administration at a time
when both
the secretary of state mike pompeo has
been going around
uh various u.s allies
trying to do what he can in the last few
weeks
specifically in terms of israel
presumably to try to circumscribe
the room for action for an incoming baid
administration he did that in terms of
declaring the anti-occupation movement
bds
uh as anti-semitic as far as the united
states was concerned also saying that
all
settlement-made goods would be declared
as israeli
as far as the u.s market is concerned
those are both things that biden would
have to
explicitly unpick and could be difficult
for him to do so the question is
is there something similar brewing with
saudi arabia
is this about what netanyahu wants to do
to try to
circumscribe u.s action versus iran
certainly he's sent a very public
message to joe biden saying that going
back to the 2015 iran nuclear deal
would be a mistake so i think it's
unlikely
that we're going to see full
normalization between saudi saudi arabia
and israel
before trump leaves office but it
certainly can be seen in
in terms of those wider efforts to try
to shore up what four years of trump
has meant in terms of foreign policy
thank you harry fawcett
the news or reports at least of prime
minister netanyahu
visiting saudi arabia